open up your Custom Gold bug boxes watch
mine's full of poo thankfully we have
another Banger from Mike Flanigan who
brought us such Classics as the haunting
of hillh housee and midnight mass
there's a lot to cover here including
who Verna actually is which by the way
her name is an anagram for Raven the
fate of the Usher family and how Luke
Skywalker fits into all this that's
impossible but before we begin to make
sure to like And subscribe or I'll have
to go back to my old job where I was
treated like this Tina my name isn't
Tina know that my name is Beth I don't
give a Beth The Fall of the House
of Usher revolves around head of the
Usher family and president of fortunado
pharmaceuticals rodri Usher it's
interesting to note that Frank langela
langela was originally cast as rodri but
had to be fired due to misconduct
allegations thus all his scenes were
reshot Bruce Greenwood then came in to
fill the role who I thought did a
phenomenal job and he's been in past
Flanigan works such as Gerald's Game we
can even see Gerald's Game on the TV in
the background in episode 6 as a fun
little Easter egg now we're talking
rodri has summoned assistant DA August
dupan a detective character founded
Edgar Allen po short stories to confess
all his crimes this comes in the wake of
the death of his six children yes in the
past week the dude has lost all six of
his children each in unusual and
gruesome ways but to understand how we
got here we must travel back to 1953
there we meet rodrik's Mother Eliza
who's played by Annabeth Gish who you
may remember from Midnight Mass and
Haunting of Hill housee she was
secretary to William Longfellow played
by Robert Long Street who you also might
have seen in midnight mass in hillh
house William had an affair with Eliza
which resulted in the births of twins
rodri and meline he pretty much disowned
the kids and had Eliza raise them on her
own even shunning them when Eliza's
Health took a turn for the worse seeing
his mom in so much pain fueled rodri to
pursue a career in medicine hoping to
one day create a product that could ease
Humanity's suffering so he ends up
getting an entry-level job at the same
company that so cruy treated his mother
fortunado enter Rufus Griswald the
misogynous bastard of a CEO played by
Michael tro who you may remember as Wade
from Midnight Mass not only does he
treat mateline like a piece of meat when
she comes to him with a way to
computerize the company but he steals
rodri's painkiller idea forges documents
and covers up deaths caused by their
products he even goes so far as to dig
up corpses of the company's victim so
there would be no evidence so meline and
rodri devise a way to get back at Rufus
and simultaneously take control of the
company this idea was spurred by their
first foster family the moldun we never
meet the moldun but according to meline
they were fostering kids just to collect
their government checks so unlike rodri
who rebelled against them meline made
herself useful to the munes even giving
them tips on how to cut more corners I
made myself their favorite of all of the
kids over time she gained their trust
which allowed her access to their secret
ledgers which she eventually turned into
the police to have them arrested if they
can gain rufus's trust it may offer them
an opportunity to stab him in the back
enter young August dupan who wants to
expose Rufus and for chanat for their
crimes with rodri as an informant they
can finally take fortunado down but on
the day of his deposition rodri
backstabs dupan and says he has no
knowledge of any wrongdoing this is all
a calculated plan by rodri and mine to
get in rufus's good books by Saving
rufus's and fortunato's ass rodri gets
that new promotion is showered in money
and gets the new office right next to
the CEO this does not go over well with
rodri's first wife Annabelle Lee a
character named after the famous po poem
she's played by Katie Parker who you may
remember as Poppy Hill from The Haunting
of hillh housee rather than do the right
thing her husband has chosen greed and
this decision ultimately has her file
for for divorce but mateline and rodri's
plan doesn't end there they want Rufus
to pay so mateline seduces Rufus not
that hard to do since he already tried
hitting on her and she brings him down
into the under construction offices to
drug and chain him up behind a wall
we'll see that this whole area is still
under construction 40 years later so it
looks like when rodri took over he put a
stop to it just in case someone went
looking wall analogies and metaphors are
littered all throughout the series from
Pink Floyd's at Brick in the Wall
playing at the start of episode 1 to
dialogue from our characters together
this is about forming a wall
she's in the walls that family firewall
you've always talked about it's being
dismantled one brick at a time the plan
to Barry Rufus behind this wall at New
Year's meant the office would be on
vacation for an entire week but not to
worry meline said she slipped him enough
cyanide that he'll be dead by morning
this is also why rodri is haunted by a
Jester the cost costume Rufus was
wearing the night he was murdered to
provide themselves with an alibi the two
make their way to a local bar and this
is when their lives change forever there
they meet Verna an unassuming bartender
who turns out to be more than she seems
she somehow knows meline and rodri
killed Rufus and offers them a deal in
exchange for a life of luxury and excess
free from any repercussions they must
forfeit their bloodline upon rodri's
death any Offspring they have will die
with them into the world together out of
the world together or there is no deal
that's what she said and Verna makes a
pretty compelling argument here would
you rather your child live to be 50 to
60 in a life where anything they want
they can have or would you have them
live to be 70 or 80 with a life riddled
with anxiety and tribulation at this
point rodri had already lost his wife
and kids to divorce and meline will
never have kids so both of them decide
to take this deal when they leave the
bar it mysteriously vanishes and the two
go on about their lives wondering if
what they experienced ever even happened
although the show never explicitly
States who or what Verna is there are
several clues that point to her being a
malevolent Supernatural Force here are
all the facts we know about her one
she's not human we see her killed
multiple times only to come back
completely unscathed in episode 6 meline
even grabs her and she turns into black
dust two Verna can shape shift turning
into a chimpanzee Black Cat and of
course Edgar and Po's famous Raven if
you switch around the letters of Verna
you get the word Raven and her in Raven
form can be found all throughout the
season peering down at rodri outside the
funeral and at dupan top the ruins of
the Usher house among several other
times as Verna States The Raven is often
a symbol of death but in some culture
it's a symbol of Fortune death and
Fortune is what she brings to the ushers
three Verna can mimic other people's
voices she takes on Frederick's voice to
tell the demolition team to start their
work work four Verna has been around
long before humans existed remarking how
she watched as humans first built cities
this ties into her being Immortal or at
least old enough to have been around for
thousands of years we'll see Arthur Pim
dig up these photos of her from the past
Century photos of her with billionaire
David Co Supreme Court Justice Brett
Kavanaugh and Republican Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell there are a lot
more here but it implies she made deals
with all of them similar to the one she
made with rodri and meline five she can
mind control her victims like how she
made Frederick put the paralytic drug
Nightshade into his own drugs six she
can see multiple Futures and multiple
pasts while talking to meline she says
if rodri had left fortunado he would
have gone off to be a poet she tells
Frederick he would have been a dentist
ironic since he pulls out his wife's
teeth and she informs Pim of how his
life will turn out depending on what he
does next but perhaps the most damning
evidence that Verna is some sort of
Minion of Satan is the line she delivers
to Pim but you're so damn
interesting that's why I had to go
topside topside implying that she comes
from below from hell she even refers to
herself as a quote witness of suffering
and pain ironic since Rodrick built his
life around ending pain something deep
down he knew was a lie that he pedal to
the masses that's the biggest lie we
told you can't eliminate pain so for 40
plus years rodri and meline build for
forado into one of the richest companies
in the world the irony is that rodri
becomes just like the man he hated Rufus
he's complicit in covering up deaths
caused by their medication exploits his
workers and basically has sex with
anyone he chooses fostering four bastard
children the reason rodri allows these
children all the luxuries and privileges
of his legitimate children is that he
knows they will die with him too if
you're an
usher the gates are open Period rodri
even uses the same s things as his late
boss we are all at Battle Stations right
now I am the commanding officer and I
don't want to hear anything out of your
mouth that isn't sir yes sir Battle
Stations I'm the commanding officer I
don't want to hear anything but sir yes
sir in episode one rodri gets some
distressing news from his doctor we
never hear what this diagnosis is until
episode 4 rodri has catacel a form of
vascular dementia and he doesn't have
long to live this is the same inherited
disease his mother had this this is why
rodri was so insistent that victorine's
heart mesh device worked it could
potentially lengthen his life and thus
the lives of his children meline on the
other hand took a different approach
she's always been obsessed with
immortality collecting rare Egyptian
artifacts since the ancient Egyptians
believed one's Soul could live forever
this is why rodri buries her alongside
items belonging to the famous Queen tus
of Egypt these items included the very
gems embedded into TT's eyes items that
took an extreme amount of of money and
pull to acquire it makes me question
whether rodri planned to kill meline
months in advance while immortality may
not be achievable in spirit form
mateline thinks it can be done digitally
she's been working on a project that can
recreate one's Consciousness on a
digital cloud and her first trial
subject is her granddaughter Lenor Edgar
alen Poe used the name Lenor in several
of his works most notably the poem The
Raven in which the narrator Mourns the
loss of his beloved Lenor the name
evokes a sense of sorrow and tragedy
fitting considering what happens to the
character in the show Leno's digital
Consciousness went live upon Leno's
death and now it incessantly texts rodri
with the word Nevermore the same word
The Raven torments the narrator in the
poem with rodri's death on the horizon
Verna comes to collect rodri's bloodline
and to make things a little more
palatable each of his children vary on
just how evil they are we have Prospero
who only cares about the success of his
pop-up nightclub exclusively for
millionaires where no rules apply he
threatens to stab his friend with a fork
and plans to have sex with his
sister-in-law he'll die in a tragic acid
incident when the sprinklers that go off
at his nightclub were found to contain
illegal chemicals fortunado was hiding
from inspectors the next is Camille
whose company makes Fox News look like a
saint she can spin any information to
her will and this largely entails
covering up or downplaying fortunato's
misdeeds she also treats her assistants
like and requires them to have sex
with her she dies when one of
victorine's test chimps mauls her to
death next is victorine who engages into
legal animal testing killing chimps and
replacing them with new ones in a
feverish attempt to make her heart mesh
work she'll end up going crazy and
performing a murder suicide Napoleon is
the prince of gaming he cheats on his
boyfriend tries to cover up the death of
his cat by replacing it with a new one
in is a notorious drug dealer he
believes the cat has gotten into the
walls and eventually chases it over the
ledge of his apartment plummeting to his
death tamberlane wants to start a health
and wellness company when her whole life
is anything but healthy and well she
makes her husband perform these weird
scenarios with prostitutes treats them
like and tells him she was just
using him to get her new company off the
ground it's pretty ironic that a woman
obsessed with self-image dies by shards
of mirrored glass then there's Frederick
who may just be the most messed up of
the bunch to get back at his wife for
attending his half brother's sex party
he keeps her acidb bured body drugged up
and away from doctors to make matters
worse he creepily posts their wedding
pictures all over the walls as a
reminder of what she did Frederick has
often been considered the toothless son
of his father so it's pretty messed up
that he removes the teeth of his wife
he'll end up dying in the very building
he sought to destroy after Verna had him
pour scoops of nightshade a fortune out
a paralytic into his stash of drugs the
only truly innocent victim in the bunch
is Lenor Verna even laments having to
kill such a sweet child and she gets off
lightly with a single touch to the
forehead but Leno's death isn't in vain
Leno's mother will go on to create the
Lenor foundation for victims of abuse
and over the next decade it will save
millions of lives perhaps the most
tragic character is Arthur Pim the
fortunado lawyer he has no spouse
friends or children fearing those he
loved could be leveraged against him
collateral leverage we never really do
find out what tragedies befell him on
his trans globe Expedition Vera hints
that it involved leaving a man in the
desert an injured Inuit guide hit by
Friendly Fire and a cannibalistic act
that Arthur did not partake in Pim calls
Humanity a virus perhaps he saw the
worst of Humanity on that expedition and
working for for chado certainly wouldn't
have opened his eyes to the good
Humanity can do my favorite shot of him
is when Vera caresses his face it's
almost as if it's the first time he's
been touched in decades and he basks in
the moment Pim will end up being
arrested with mountains of evidence
collected by Camille's assistance
helping put him away for good in his
defense he doesn't say a word the final
death is of rodri Usher himself Verna
shows him piles of bodies raining from
the sky a symbol of the millions of
people he and his company have killed
stating that he is in the top five
Killers throughout all of humanity it's
at this moment that rodri is instructed
to call dupan leading us to his
confession there's also this flashback
to what I thought was one of the most
interesting scenes of dialogue of the
series in which meline tries to justify
her actions rodri mateline and fortunado
is not the problem rather Society why do
we create a political system in which
women can't make decisions over their
own body A system that turns men into
fountains and women into factories
to provide an impoverished Workforce
that sole purpose is to consume we teach
people to want houses they can't afford
cars that poison the air and products
created by Starving Children in third
world countries why then are we the bad
guys it's it's a speech that attempts to
exonerate any of her culpability in a
company that's killed Millions it's kind
of like a drug dealer saying hey you
can't blame me for that overdose I
didn't put the drugs in their system and
as she finishes this big speech it's
rodri who ends up drugging and killing
her a complete reversal from the second
last episode where meline told rodri the
only way to save themselves was if he
killed himself and it's pretty ironic
that he does this by overdosing on his
own drug rodri prepares her body like
the Egyptian queen tet after rodri's
confession the house begins to shake and
crumble but not before mine appears and
chokes rodri to death just like his
mother Eliza came back and choked their
father to death it's left up to the
viewer on whether or not these are their
resurrected corpses or whether they were
even dead in the first place I like to
think more of the supernatural the house
collapses leaving a shock dupan with a
fleeting image of Verna above the rubble
it is the literal Fall of the House of
Usher dupan retires putting away that
corkboard which was once filled with
everything to do with the ushers Juno
rodri's wife weans herself off lione and
starts her own rehab Association you
might think it's odd that a man who
spent most of his life trying to bring
down the ushers leaves rodri's
confession but in all honesty what good
is it going to do it's not going to
bring anyone back anyone in the Usher
family who did something bad is dead or
in jail as dupan says now is the time to
heal dupan leaves stating that he's the
richest man in the world not rich in
terms of wealth but the love of his
family something Annabelle Lee told
rodri he did not have I look at you and
I see the poverty of you Verna ends up
placing momentos on the graves of the
Usher family each one symbolizing an
aspect of their life a mask for Prospero
a phone for Camille cat caller for
Napoleon the heart mesh for victorine
the gold bug Scarab for Tammy drugs for
Frederick a raven feather with white
rose for Lenor two stretz gems for
meline and a whiskey glass for rodri
Verna did say that the million-dollar
whiskey he enjoys in front of dupan
should only be drunk on two occasions on
the best day of your life or your last
day on Earth and that's certainly true
for rodri as the camera focuses on Verna
in funeral Tire we cut to a wide shot
and Verna is not there she's been
replaced by a raven who ushers toward
the camera thus ends The Fall of the
House of Usher a tragic tale about greed
corruption love and loss I really
enjoyed this series and would put it
slightly behind hillh housee and
midnight mass in my list of Flanigan
series but now I want to hear what you
thought about Usher leave your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching please be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Tina name isn't Tina you
know that my name is Beth I don't give a
Beth